Chris you and Liam are you finally going
to be in a film together
your brother Liam pops ah what we're
looking may be nice if the right thing
came along she also I read that you'd
found something you haven't found
something no no wow what if we found Ron
no no an ocean road movie two brothers
who's the father I know was he also up
for Thor he was yeah I auditioned and
then didn't get the part and then they
auditioned him and he basically got down
to last like four people and then didn't
get it and then I came back in and and
how was that at home that's like real
sibling rivalry was it oh right it must
have been a bit weird
it'll walk oh we still don't talk that
much but we never do no no it was fine
yeah I don't know whether he's bitter or
not but he did post this picture of his
this is real this is his dog with a chew
toy which looks familiar
oh yeah Hannah was delicious it was
because Ron Howard you work with your
family like all the time whenever
whenever I can
my brother Clint's an actor my father
Rance is is still acting in his 80s and
working all the time I love to I love to
work with him and your mom sadly is no
longer with us but she did get apartheid
was Apollo 13 Apollo 13 she had a really
a really nice role which almost didn't
happen because I got this call from my
dad um and and he said you know I just
read the rewrite on Apollo 13 and I said
yeah he said there's a new part in there
I said yeah there is Jim Lovells mother
I said yeah she's got a nice scene I
said yeah you know it'd be really good
for that who do you think dad your mom
boy I don't know I'd have to audition
her and and he said well uh fine and and
and so uh and my mom is all for that and
she said I don't I don't want to do it
if Ronnie doesn't think I can do it I
went over to their house and we worked
through the scene and she was great and
we did it in a couple of takes and she
was I never been prouder and she was
even got written up in the New York
Times review and it was a wound up being
a great moment she played Jim Lovells
mother would have been worse if you
hadn't given her the part off the
audition yeah this isn't going to work
out oh it's really bad my dad's an actor
I cast him whenever it's appropriate you
know and here's the call I've had to
make to him hey Dad you know that you
did great oh but you know the movie was
a little long and next would be am I in
it at all maybe in the extended DVD
Lily can you understand anything I know
I got something about balls Charley like
blend in and yo research and just
getting heckled left and right about you
know come spend some time in my shell
baby